Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video Io sono favi j vi
avevo detto ragazzi nel precedente video
che avrei sperimentato nel fare cose no
E ovviamente Questo si tratta di un
esperimento un esperimento che avevo in
mente da un sacco di tempo e ho fatto
uscire un pezzo musicale Adesso facciamo
la Reaction perché tra l'altro voglio
spiegarvi anche due robe Però è stato
pubblicato con lo pseudonimo Lore che è
il mio pseudonimo da cantante non ho
usato Favij che non c'entra niente con
questa cosa ma poi ci arriviamo Ecco
questo non è il video Questa è due Lip
andiamo avanti
qua fuori è pieno di supereroi Tra
l'altro raga Qua abbiamo ogni scena
riprende un film questo è Leon non so se
l'avete visto Guardatelo è molto bello
ed è per questo che ho sto berretto
orribile in testa tra l'altro canzone
sta partendo un po' triste dammi
qualcosa che carica che mi risale la
Stamina Sta vita un sapore di plastica
metto un po' di paprica poi trema la
camera un nella manica non ascolto la
Ecco questa è strana perché non c'è
rinculo quando io sparo non c'è rinculo
cioè proprio vedi il fucile che è fermo
immobile questa cosa un po' strana però
vabbè Ovviamente non è perfetto
raga ora queste scene e molti non se ne
sono accorti perché questo è incredibile
ragazzi Questa è cgi queste scene non
sono vere ok Quindi io non ho guidato
ovviamente cioè questa è New York City
non so se ve ne siete accorti però
questa è cgi sono scene fatte al
computer ed è
incredibile che siano riuscite a farle
così bene uno shoutout ai ragazzi che
l'hanno fatto ve lo lasci ve li lascio
anche qua in descrizione il i crediti
perché sono veramente stati incredibili
ragazzi Ma che roba hanno fatto cioè sta
roba è assurda L'unica cosa che manca se
vogliamo mettere i puntini sulle i in
queste scene è un po' di dinamismo
mancano altre macchine che vanno in giro
mancano le persone ai lati sui
marciapiedi Quindi volendo proprio
mettere i puntini sulle i non è una
scena completamente perfetta Però
ragazzi dai
[Musica]
Questa è la scena più bella secondo me
ragazzi Anche qui ragazzi L'idea
iniziale era quella di utilizzare delle
scene fatte al computer quindi magari
con loro ricreati al computer con il
fuoco Tutto fatto in CJ tutto finto però
che comunque sei fatto bene
è è una scena Forte quindi non sapendo
se potevo caricare una cosa del genere o
meno ho detto No vabbè ragazzi non la
facciamo facciamo vedere solo che
facciamo così e poi mettiamo la casa che
va a fuoco da da fuori sì ma anche meno
che è questa qua che tra l'altro ragazzi
Anche questa è cgi cioè questa è finta
non c'era la casa là Questo era un campo
verde completamente fake tra l'altro è è
la parte dove si vede di più che questo
è cgi Ovviamente questa è la parte dove
si capisce è l'effetto meno venuto bene
tra tutti secondo me quindi si si
capisce abbastanza e ovvi amente Questo
è il Meme della bambina che guarda in
camera quando la casa Va a fuoco Questa
è stata questa la ciliegina sul
[Musica]
video qua mi ero spacc ragazzi Qua mi
sono fatto malissimo qua mi ero
veramente spaccato il culo Cioè sonoa
qua Questo non è questo non è recitato
mi sono fatto male sul serio qua sono
spaccato tutto E
[Musica]
vabbè Ma a me non
interessa se sto con certa gente Mi sale
il delinquente che ho dentro nella testa
questa scena Ragazzi io non volevo fare
un video pieno di comparse conosciute
cioè perché il classico video dello
youtuber che fa una canzone e che prende
tutti i suoi amici e g fa fare piccole
parti per tutto il video Ok io non
volevo questo non essendo questa una
canzone da youtuber perché non l'ho
pubblicata neanche come Favij ho detto
No io non voglio fare un video da
youtuber classico perché non è niente di
tutto ciò Al massimo faccio una scena ma
una proprio una sola Dove metto i miei
amici Insomma che hanno voglia di
partecipare Infatti qua ci dovevano
essere anche i Pantellas che poi non
sono venuti perché avevano da fare
perché non ci sono mai per per gli amici
loro quando ce n'è bisogno andiamo
avanti
ragazzi del tuo consenso Se vuoi ti
presto un cello e passi perest fare
l'est pare pazzesco a non vederci presto
non mi basta fare questa Sca È
incredibile vado Dr Ah ovv mi sono
dimenticato di dirvi Ovviamente questo è
un riferimento a Fast and Furious Simone
che è mio amico somiglia molto a Toretto
Tra l'altro alla fine delle riprese
abbiamo fatto una foto che è veramente
molto simile a una foto fatta nel
backstage di Fast and Furious che è
questa vi faccio vedere comunque
riferimento a Fast and Furious e invece
riferimento della casa questo qua è di
Funny games se non Avete visto neanche
quel film Guardatelo F in Furio se
l'avete visto tutti quindi inutile che
ve lo dico che
vuo vado dritto faccio come la cassa
voglio fare più rumore come quando passa
una Mustang Io voglio dare alle
fiamme che vi devo dire signori Cioè ma
poi ci sono anche le c'è anche il wrap
alle Ali cioè le ali sono wrappate come
la mia macchina questa cosa è
incredibile Cioè questo è un modello
importato nella demo di Matrix loro
hanno giocato Cioè questo è un Gameplay
ripreso un Gameplay come se io registr
ma non so parlare quindi andiamo
avanti mi avot
le Allora ragazzi Questa cosa l'effetto
della macchina cioè allora Questo
ovviamente è green screen sui vetri però
la macchina si muove un po' come se
stesse volando avete notato che si muove
un po' la macchina vedete che si muove
questo effetto è stato fatto con delle
persone che spingevano la macchina da
ferma e continuavano a squat mii la
macchina così e quindi sembra che si
muova Sì ma anche
meno e poi Qua c'è un mix di tutte le
scene tu stai guardando in camera
comunque
[Musica]
eh questa raga è andata a culo non
doveva essere così cioè io a un certo
punto io dovevo fare dei balletti
davanti a loro balletti randomici qua ho
lanciato il berretto da golfista proprio
l'ho preso l'ho lanciato e è finito
sulla camera e quindi abbiamo sfruttato
la la la situazione per poter fare Poi
questa scena qua dove ci sono Giampiero
e Daniele lui Giampiero lo conoscete
Daniele no che è il regista del video
Daniele Bagolin è il mio amico Infatti è
tutta la produzione fatta tra noi amici
questa cosa è assurda perché è venuto
bene Secondo me il video benissimo pur
essendo tra di noi capito È stata una
grande scommessa per tutti quanti Quindi
è una scena che include coloro che hanno
lavorato dietro le quinte in regia
Praticamente sì ma anche meno e infatti
finisce così ragazzi Questo è anche meno
è stata È stata veramente una scommessa
pazzesca che io volevo fare da un sacco
di tempo e quindi Ragazzi Adesso vi
spiego al volo che cosa succe cosa sta
succedendo perché tutto ciò come avevo
detto nel video precedente qua su Favij
Io sto sperimentando sto facendo cose
cose che magari ho sempre voluto fare
cose nuove idee che mi vengono in mente
adesso cose ok E vediamo quale strada eh
mi aggrada di più dico mi aggrada di più
perché si parla di quello che io voglio
fare ok Non quello che necessariamente
vuole il pubblico quello che io voglio
fare Ho notato che con anche meno il
feedback è stato incredibilmente
positivo ma è stata una scommessa perché
vi spiego quando tu sei conosciuto molto
conosciuto per qualcosa nel mio caso io
sono conosciuto perché perché faccio
perché ho sempre fatto video video su
YouTube video gameplay video su Happy
Wheels Ok quando io dico non mi basta
fare solo ciò che vuole la massa vado
dritto faccio come la cassa è proprio un
riferimento a questo Cioè vado dritto
con i miei pensieri faccio quello che ho
voglia di fare ok indipendentemente da
quello che pensa la gente ed è
importante e so che questa cosa non
verrà comunque assimilata da tutti
perché per molti anche dovessi diventare
conosciutissimo in ambito musicale per
molti sono comunque quello che ha fatto
Happy Wheels ok E va bene cioè ci sta
scindere le cose è molto difficile ma
questa canzone ed è molto importante che
voi lo capiate non è la canzone di Favij
non ho creato un canale exnovo ho rbr
jvf Perché tanto era lì inutilizzato e
non sarebbe più stato utilizzato e ho
creato una vera e propria scissione tra
Favij e Lore che è un'altra cosa
Ovviamente se io avessi caricato il
video su questo canale avrebbe molte più
views banalmente e sarebbe molto più
conosciuto dalla mia fan base ma non
volevo fare questo perché fare questo
significava fare la canzone dello
youtuber preferisco avere molti meno
numeri ma tutti veritieri cioè di gente
interessata al progetto potrebbe non
avere successo questa cosa e però ho
detto Sto sperimentando sono in un
periodo in cui sperimento facciamolo è
molto difficile molto difficile cercare
di far capire alla gente che non sei
solo una roba Puoi fare anche altro
soprattutto in un periodo di mutazione
dove io non faccio più Happy Wheels Ok
faccio altre robe magari funziona magari
no però vabbè intanto ci ho provato E
sti cazzi è stato un ci siamo divertiti
e mi sono divertito e mi sto tutt'ora
divertendo quindi è già un successo per
me è già ok E il feedback ragazzi è
stato incredibile siete stati
incredibili Io non so come ringraziarvi
Veramente io non pensavo così
tanto Forse perché era da tanto che non
io avevo sempre fatto parodie forse era
perché era da tanto che non facevo un
progetto così ben strutturato e ho visto
tantissimo affetto cioè Raga grazie Non
non avrei mai immaginato una cosa del
genere quindi grazie di cuore veramente
cioè il primo giorno quando sono usciti
i video gente che ha iniziato a fare a
usare la canzone su tiktok magari per
per come Trend per per per i video
tiktok ho iniziato a dire No ragazzi
Vabbè inizio a repostar VII e quindi da
adesso cioè da da ieri ho iniziato anche
a repostare chi su tiktok utilizza la
mia canzone per fare come Trend
sostanzialmente per fare dei tiktok
quindi ragazzi se volete fare dei tiktok
dei contenuti eh sappiate che io li
guardo tutti Li sto guardando tutti
perché mi basta poi vedere chi utilizza
la canzone e il contenuto che ha
pubblicato quindi me li guardo tutti i
più creativi li ripubblico Quindi se
volete farlo fatelo Sicuramente io li
guardo e li reposto quindi ehm Grazie
comunque per questo cioè veramente mi
fate
bene all'anima non saprei come altro
dirlo è una bellissima cosa quindi
ragazzi in conclusione Questo è un
progetto nuovo che penso porterò avanti
perché il feedback è stato super
positivo ci tengo a precisare che
comunque sia io ho voluto fare un pezzo
che ricordasse un po' lo spirito
parodistico delle parodie che avevo
fatto un tempo quindi TS in Italia
pagherai tu e tutte le altre no perché
anche se è un altro ramo della mia
carriera è un po' strano iniziare a fare
pezzi troppo seri ok perché comunque hai
sempre fatto tutt'altro quindi ci vuole
un qualcosa di transizione e questo è la
transizione anche meno è la transizione
dal mondo parodistico al mondo musicale
Si colloca in mezzo i prossimi pezzi
possono anche non avere ironia Anche se
comunque è innata in me come persona
quindi credo che la vena ironica farà
comunque sempre un po' parte di me anche
dall'altra dell'altro ramo della mia
carriera Quindi Lore perché sono io
comunque trovate ragazzi il link della
canzone qua in descrizione ci rivediamo
In un prossimo video qua perché ah
parentesi finale Minchia Prima che mi
dimentico Ovviamente questo non va ad
oscurare Favij vuol dire che Favij andrà
avanti con le sue cose nell'ultimo
periodo sto facendo meno contenuti però
non è che smetto di fare video eh
tranquilli cioè io continuo a fare video
Anzi ne ho uno in canna che è bellissimo
Secondo me tra un po' esce perché l'ho
già registrato e tutto però tranquilli
non non sto ripudiando Favij creo questo
battibecco che era un po' lo stesso
battibecco che c'era tra Favij e jivaf
perché mi piace in qualche modo avere
queste due personalità che non c'entrano
nulla l'una con l'altra che si si si
azzannano un po' mi fa mi fa ridere come
cosa però ovviamente Favij continua
tranquilli eh cioè questa è una non
pensavo neanche di doverla fare sta
specifica Ma qualcuno mi ha scritto
nelle storie tipo Eh ma questo vuol dire
che smetti di là No no tranquillo
tranquillo Quindi ragazzi Spero che
questo video vi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi
al canale anche al canale di Lore che vi
lascio in descrizione così come il pezzo
e Seguitemi anche su Spotify che è
importante continuate ad ascoltare anche
meno e se volete appunto fate qualche
tiktok qualche contenuto che io lo
ripubblico perché li guardo tutti e noi
ci vediamo come sempre ad un prossimo
video che uscirà tra non molto ragazzi
Preparatevi perché è un contenuto
pazzesco Eh ho perso il telecomando in
St settimane Io comunque Passano gli
anni il telecomando in qualche modo lo
perderò sempre però è sempre rimasto lo
stesso quindi questo in un museo finisce
prima o poi questo Eh ve lo dico bella
ragazzi